et on retrouve Pauline Godard vous étiez
également il y a quelques jours à
saporija comment vivent les
Ukrainiens le fait de vivre près de
cette centrale
alors écoutez il est vrai que à l'heure
actuelle ce n'est pas l'inquiétude du
moment de vivre à côté de cette centrale
ils nous ont expliqué que ça l'avait été
à un moment donné notamment cet été mais
plus maintenant ce qu'il redoute surtout
à l'heure actuelle ce sont les
bombardements ils gardent bien sûr en
tête le fait qu'il y ait cette centrale
nucléaire juste à côté ils le savent
mais comme ils nous l'ont expliqué cette
hors de leur contrôle alors ils doivent
faire avec comme je vous le disais le
redoutes surtout les bombardements la
ville de porridja est très régulièrement
bombardé il y a très souvent des alertes
nous y étions et il y a quelques jours
nous y étions également au mois de
décembre il est vrai qu'au mois de
décembre la ville est très très
régulièrement frappée notamment au
niveau de ses infrastructures
énergétiques la situation de ce côté-là
c'est un petit peu amélioré puisqu'on a
constaté quand même cette fois-ci il n'y
a pas eu de coupure de courant comme
c'était le cas au moins de décembre nous
avons parlé avec Alexandra qui tient un
café elle elle nous a expliqué avoir
confiance censé soldats confiance en la
victoire mais qu'elle était inquiète
pour eux puisque ils viennent très
régulièrement boire des cafés les voies
très régulièrement c'est certains sont
devenus des amis elle nous a expliqué
bien que c'était dur et qu'elle pensait
à eux et qu'elle essayait de leur
apporter le maximum nos réconforts et
d'être présent pour eux avant qu'il
parte sur le front et puis c'est
habitants nous apportent déjà des
Aborigènes où sont aussi confiés et bien
que pour eux ça pourrait déjà était une
forteresse une forteresse imprenable et
qu'ils étaient persuadés que de toute
façon les Russes n'arriveraient jamais à
l'apprendre puisqu'elle était bien
gardée par les soldats Ukrainiens merci
beaucoup Pauline Godard on dirait que de
cramatorze merci à vous et pour votre
portage également